in this video we'll be talking about the
jackstack pathway inhibitor tofas City
nip which is frequently used for
treatment of several Rheumatic disease
like rheumatoid
arthritis then psorasis or ulcerative
col colitis so this particular molecule
inhibits the jaat pathway we would learn
why it is important it's a oral
medication which is very efficient so
let's talk about in bit more details
from a technical and structural point of
view this particular molecule block the
genus sky or Jack Jack has several
domains like the kyes domain which
regulates
phosphorilation then pudines domain sh2
and farm domain so in order for Jack to
phosphorate any Target protein it needs
ATP without ATP any kyes protein cannot
do the phosphorilation job
so in this context tastin actually
competitively inhibits this particular
uh protein so it it competes with ATP to
bind to the
jackyes and thereby inhibiting its own
activity now let's put this idea into
the context of a Rheumatic disease or
autoimmune disease let's say we are
talking about rheumatoid arthritis
in this case the joints of the bones are
severely affected so here is the
sinovial membrane here is the fibras
capsule and here is the sinovial fluid
so there are Auto antibodies which kind
of damage specific cells known as sovio
sites so there are uh complement
mediated damage of these cells so these
migm anti Auto antibodies lead to
complement fixation and liis of these
sovio site alongside this mechanism
there are several cell types involved in
these disease progression such as macras
dendritic cells and also th1 subtype
cells which triggers the inflammatory
response in the joints and that's why
the joints are inflamed in these kind of
autoimmune disorders so one of the key
focus in these disease is the uh
pro-inflammatory cyto kind shown here
what if this PL pro-inflammatory cyto
production can be paused or seized then
there would be a a better treatment for
this particular
disease exactly tofas cin does that
function so all these pro-inflammatory
cyto kindes are produced by the jaat
pathway so the jaat pathway starts with
the particular cyto binding or ligan
binding to the cyto receptor which lead
to the dimerization of the receptor then
the janosky binds to the receptor and
and phosphorites a portion of these
receptor eventually it attracts the
stats or signal transduction and
transmission proteins so these stats
bind to the receptor and Jack can
phosphorate stats as well once
phosphorilated stat proteins are
activated they dimerize with each other
and now they're free to move to the
nucleus inside the nucleus they actually
take part in trans description because
they bind to cyto response element and
it triggers specific Gene
activation many of these genes are
actually the cyto kind genes especially
the pro-inflammatory ones so obviously
we can understand if we have a
particular drug that can potentially
block the cyto production would be
really beneficial so tastin blocks the
Jack and thereby prevents all the
downstream signaling via this Jack stat
signaling arm and thereby tastin rescues
uh the day with preventing the
inflammatory cyto production so already
we have discussed that tastin acts as a
competitive inhibitor for a competitive
inhibitor for the jasky so it competes
with ATP and thereby preventing ATP to
bind to the is domain of the Jack
protein and thereby the Jack proteins
are non-functional cannot transduce the
signal
Downstream but when we talk about tacb
there are certain side effects that one
need to understand with tasb there could
be increase risk of serious bacterial
viral infections also there could be
gastrointestinal and liver complications
there could be changes in the blood cell
count and also there could be D
lipidemia which can be associated with
toac so both sides has to be considered
before administering this particular
drug so that is why Consulting a
physician is really important in this
context so I hope this was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe get notes and flash cards in
our Facebook and Instagram page links
are provided in the
description you can support our Channel
using super thanks you can contribute
using PTM PayPal or UPI see you in next
video
R
run